this was Paris before the final group
stage games the mood was low in the
cafes and pubs that screen the matches
were often empty there are many strikes
here that's why not so much attention is
given to Europe 2016 during the match of
France yeah we have a lot of people
supporting friends but of the day it's
like okay we don't care about football
what happened six months ago I think
it's maybe in everybody's head we also
do the atmosphere in France is not at
all comparable to the one during the
world cup in 1998 back then zinedine
zidane left France turds first world cup
title in United the nation today those
memories have long faded France advanced
to the last 16 but this barely a trace
of euphoria the lack of interest has
also been bad for business nasty to me
we ordered everything just look we
thought people would buy jerseys of the
teams they support but that didn't
happen here is a purpose about our
football doesn't inspire the French so
easily especially in Paris you are him
barbiere wrote a book about why the
French are so indifferent when it comes
to football contrary to what people
think abroad the French are not so proud
to be French in Paris you wouldn't wear
the jersey for are going to work you
know that scare you know the kind of
thing that you see everywhere but not
here in France the only time the mood on
the streets of Paris picks up is when
fans from across Europe arrive and
gather around the stadiums
I live what sees the French are a bit
reserved they don't know how to party
he's on he's on you motherf elephant at
the same time considering all the
distress you'd think the French would
find inspirations from other fans if you
would ask to the French people in the
street can we sing a song together a
French film it would be impossible to
find one all of Europe meets at the fan
zone under the Eiffel Tower despite the
security checks and moderate rather the
fan zone doesn't even reach full
capacity on most days but that doesn't
dampen the mood for those who do come we
are we gonna win it but he had to be
outside you'll be good like yeah it's
good
can the feelings of 1998 return to this
country I don't think that national team
success can bring and cure all the
issues that this country is going
through at the moment it would be it
would be like a nice week after but
after but later on winning the title
could help a nation heal after the
recent terror attacks good luck leibler